Imagine you're navigating this massive pitch black maze, right? Right. You're looking for a specific prize hidden somewhere in there, but you only have a flashlight and the batteries are dying fast.
Not an ideal situation.
Right. Every time you turn down a corridor, your flashlight dims just a little bit more. If you check too many empty hallways, you're going to be left completely in the dark.
Yeah. And that is exactly what experimental discovery feels like when you're constrained by time and money.
Exactly. Whether you're hunting for, you know, a new drug or optimizing a chemical reaction or designing some novel material, you are always facing that same really expensive question.
Which is which path do we eliminate next?
Yes. Because in the real world of scientific research, those flashlight batteries are million dollar budgets.
Oh, absolutely. And like months of laboratory labor, you can't just wander around hoping to bump into a breakthrough. You need a highly disciplined system.
Which brings us to our mission for today's deep dive. We are unpacking a system that completely flips the script on how we navigate that maze.
We're looking at the bleeding edge of AI and scientific discovery today.
We are. We've got a stack of six research papers in front of us, but we're really going to shine the spotlight on one absolute game changer.
Yeah, the Gollum paper.
Right. It's titled Large Language Models as Uncertainty Calibrated Optimizers for Experimental Discovery, published by Bojana Rankovic, Ryan Reis Griffiths, and Philippe Schwaller.
In Nature Machine Intelligence on August 28, 2026.
And what's so fascinating here is it tackles this massive elephant in the room with large language models, right? Like their fatal flaw.
Their overconfidence. Yeah. Foundation models, they hallucinate. They sound incredibly sure of themselves while being completely dangerously wrong.
And normally scientists try to just suppress that or they disqualify LLMs from high stakes decisions entirely. But this new framework, GOLLUM, which stands for Gaussian Process Optimized LLMs, it does something wild.
It really does. It doesn't just try to put a filter over the hallucination. It actively uses that exact flaw as a training signal.
Okay, let's unpack this because to understand why Gollum is such a profound breakthrough, we kind of need to look at the two broken compasses scientists have been using in that maze.
Right, so on one side you have traditional Bayesian optimization or BO.
Which is like the gold standard, right?
It is the absolute gold standard for experimental discovery because it handles uncertainty beautifully. It runs all this math to balance exploration. So... Checking unknown areas of the maze with exploitation.
Meaning focusing on areas we already know are decent.
Exactly. But Bayesian optimization has a massive bottleneck. It requires these hand-built, domain-specific representations.
Let me translate that for anyone who hasn't worked in a chemistry lab. If you want a computer to understand a chemical reaction, you usually have to translate it into a fingerprint.
Right. You take a complex, 3D, messy chemical reality and you smash it down into a 1D string of numbers.
Right. So the algorithm can actually read it. Like a popular one is called DRFP. But if you spend months building a Bayesian model to understand those specific reaction fingerprints, it's well, it's completely useless if you suddenly
want to optimize, say, a crystal structure.
Or a protein confirmation. Yeah, you're starting from scratch every single time you change fields. It's mathematically rigorous, but incredibly rigid.
OK, so that's compass number one. On the flip side, we have large language models.
Right. And they've ingested essentially all broad scientific literature. They offer this highly flexible natural language interface. You
just type in your problem in plain English.
Exactly. But, and this is a big but, they have zero calibrated uncertainty. They don't know what they don't know.
And if you're a lab director managing a million dollar budget, you know, an AI hallucination from ChatGPT isn't just some funny quirk you screenshot for social media.
No, it's a massive waste of resources.
In a chemistry lab, a hallucinated suggestion could literally blow up the fume hood.
You just can't risk it. And so the scientific community basically assumed you had to choose. You either take the rigorous but rigid Bayesian optimization, or you take the flexible but reckless LOM.
But the central claim of this new Gollum paper is that you don't have to choose.
Right. You can actually have both.
So how do they actually do this? How does Gollum merge the flexibility of English text with the rigor of higher level math?
So see how inevitable this breakthrough really is? We have to look backward for a second to a foundational theory from way back in 2015. Okay.
Laying the groundwork.
Yeah. The lineage is crucial here. This builds heavily on a 2015 paper by Wilson, Hu, Salikudinov, and Xing on deep kernel learning.
Right.
And that paper showed something highly technical, that you can compose a kernel, which is the mathematical function a Gaussian process uses to measure similarity, with a learned neural feature transformation. And you can train that whole system end-to-end through the Gaussian process's marginal likelihood.
Wait, hold on. Gaussian process marginal likelihood? That sounds like, I mean, a grad school hazing term. Let's ground that in an analogy so we don't lose anyone. Fair enough. Imagine you're pairing up a brilliant but highly erratic polymath, that's our language model,
with a strict probability-obsessed actuary.
Okay, the Gaussian process.
Right. Left alone, the polymath just spouts out a million creative ideas, half of which are nonsense.
And the actuary is there to calculate risk. So in the Golem framework, the actuary uses probabilistic gradients to literally train the polymath. Wow. That marginal likelihood you just mentioned, it's essentially the actuary's rulebook. It's a
mathematical score of how well the model explains the data while penalizing it for being too complex or overconfident.
So it forces the language model to only speak up when it's mathematically justified by those uncertainty objectives.
Exactly. Gollum is basically that 2015 deep kernel learning concept, but the neural feature extractor just happens to be a massive language model, and the input happens to be English text.
The theory is super elegant, but the mechanism of how this math forces a language model to learn chemistry, that's where the paper really shines for me.
Oh, totally. Because it starts by proving just how terrible static language models are at this task.
Let's look at those numbers because they're rough. If you take off the shelf static LLM embeddings and try to use them as chemical descriptors, they fail miserably.
Yeah, the paper shows that static LLM embeddings only found, what, 15% to 26% of the highest yielding reactions in their tests?
Yeah. And compare that to that specialized handcrafted reaction fingerprint we mentioned earlier, DRFP. That specialized fingerprint found 38%. The static LLM is just wandering lost in the maze.
Because the LLM is organizing its knowledge based on textual similarity, not chemical reality.
Right.
So the fix that Gollum introduces isn't to just build a bigger language model or feed it more chemistry textbooks. The fix is letting the optimization process physically reshape the LLM's representation of the world.
And this all comes down to a geometric finding in the paper, right? They measure it using something called the old ratio. Right. But you're going to have to walk me through this one because looking at the ratio of a learned length scale to an average pairwise distance
in an embedding space, that is heavy. What does that actually look like if I'm looking at a map?
Okay, let's stick with the map metaphor. Think of the optimization landscape like a physical terrain you're trying to hike.
Okay.
The Elad ratio essentially measures how smooth or chaotic that terrain is. If the ratio is high, the landscape is like a smooth rolling hill. Similar chemical experiments are clustered closely together, creating a predictable terrain where the algorithm
can easily guess where the highest point is. Got it. But if the ratio is low, the landscape is a jagged, spiked cliffside. It's chaotic. A tiny step in one direction could drop you off a cliff.
So a high ratio means a safe, predictable map. A low ratio means a dangerous, broken map.
Exactly. And across 14 different representations, that old ratio perfectly predicted optimization performance with a 0.92 correlation.
A 0.92 correlation is staggering.
It really is. It's actually a better predictor of success than the surrogate model's raw predictive accuracy. Wait, really? Yeah. It works through this phenomenon called implicit contrastive learning. The language model is being fine-tuned by the Gaussian process's marginal likelihood
that actuary is ruleable.
Right, right.
Nobody explicitly coded the AI to organize chemistry this way. But the math naturally acts as a secret contrastive loss function. It physically pulls experiments with similar outcomes closer together in the model's brain,
and it violently pushes failed experiments far apart.
OK, so by the time you reach like iteration 50 of this optimization loop, the model's internal latent space has completely reorganized itself into a chemically meaningful map.
Exactly. Even though it's just processing English text, it learns that high-yield iodide-based aryl halides are a distinct family. And it clusters them all together in the smooth rolling hill zone.
And meanwhile, it takes the low-yield chlorides and just shoves them way over into the jagged cliffside zone.
Right. And this is the ultimate answer to the AI black box objection.
Oh, because scientists hate using AI when it spits out an answer without a rationale.
Exactly. Because Gollum organizes its internal map this way, a scientist can physically inspect the AI's suggestions before they ever spend money running the experiment in the lab.
You can look at the visual representation and say, ah, okay, it's suggesting this new molecule because the model physically moved it right next to our best performing iodides.
Exactly. It's inspectable.
So as for the actual model architecture they used to build this map, they tested three variants, right? PLLM, LLM5, and PLLM5.
Yeah. And the absolute winner was the PLLM5 variant built on a T5 encoder decoder.
What is it about that specific setup that makes it win?
Well, the TFI architecture uses an encoder to read the input text and a decoder to generate the representation. The phi variant adds specific trainable layers to the network. So instead of updating the entire massive language model, which is computationally impossible for most labs,
the Gaussian process only tweaks those specific phi layers. It is highly efficient.
The real shocker for me, though, was looking at the models that failed. A specialized chemistry model, T5-TEM, actually underperformed general-purpose LLMs. I know. How does a model trained explicitly on chemistry lose a chemistry test to a general model?
Because it proves that what makes this work isn't just stuffing the model with more pre-trained chemistry data. It's the uncertainty-guided fine-tuning. A general foundation model that is actively taught how to measure its own uncertainty will beat a
chemistry-stuffed model that has no concept of its own risk. Calibration beats memorization.
Calibration beats memorization. That is such a good way to put it. Okay, so we have this beautiful inspectable internal map, a highly efficient architecture. Let's look at the scoreboard to see how it performs in the real world because, I mean, these benchmarks are intense.
They really are. They tested Gollum across 23 highly diverse optimization tasks. We're talking organic synthesis, material science, catalysis, analytical chemistry, and molecular design.
And across all 23 tasks, Gollum ranks first on average.
Yep. At a tight 50 experiment budget, Gollum hit a 36.3% top 5% coverage.
And let's look at the competition there. A model called Bohemian hit 26.5%. A model called LAPF hit just 12.1%.
And even the traditional standard Gaussian process using those expensive domain tailored representations only hit twenty nine point seven percent.
Gollum just blew past all of them.
And we have to emphasize the setup here. Every single one of these runs started completely cold.
Right. They gave the models just 10 initial low performing experiments to start with. All 10 were below the median.
Yeah.
Wait, wait. If it only knows failure, how does it know what direction success is in? Isn't it just guessing blindly at that point?
That is the brilliance of the Gaussian process guiding it. It isn't just regurgitating memorized successes from its training data. By starting with failures, it maps the boundaries of those failures. Oh, wow. The algorithm basically says, okay, this area of the maze leads to a dead end.
Let's maximize our uncertainty and check the exact opposite side of the latent space. It deduces the shape of the maze by purposefully bumping into the walls until it finds the open hallway.
And when it finds that hallway, it just sprints. On the book called Hartwig Cross Coupling Benchmark, which is a notoriously difficult chemistry problem, Golem nearly doubles the discovery rate of high yielding conditions. It hits 43 percent.
While the expert quantum chemical descriptors and the state-of-the-art LLMs were stuck down at 24 to 25%.
And it matched traditional Bayesian optimization while using a median of 41% fewer experiments.
But, you know, the biggest wins weren't even in standard synthesis. The gains are actually largest in process chemistry, going from 13.4% to 25.4%.
That is a 90% relative improvement.
Exactly. And it also dominated in mixed variable tasks where you have this messy combination of categorical choices and continuous variables jumping from 24.9% to 35.8%.
Which is huge because in those mixed variable tasks, specialized fingerprints don't even exist. Right. Traditional methods just break down completely because you can't build a clean 1D string of numbers out of a messy continuous variable.
Exactly. Now, with a scorecard this dominant, you would assume universal adoption is just right around the corner.
Right, everyone's popping champagne.
But the reality is the AI and chemistry community is highly fractured. Gollum is stepping right into the middle of a four-way crossfire in the literature.
Okay, let's sit in the tension of these conflicting papers because the disagreements are where you really see the frontier of the science.
Yeah, let's go through them. The first conflict is with Google DeepMind's OPRO paper by Yang et al. titled, Large Language Models as Optimizers.
They proposed a dead simple idea, right? Just prompt the model, tell the LLM what you want, give it the history and text, and ask for the next data point. Yeah.
And the Gollum paper tests this exact hypothesis directly. They ran the book-walled Hartwig benchmark using direct prompting on GPT-5, Gemini 2.5 Pro, Claude Sonnet 4, and Quinn.
And what happened?
The results were disastrous. They saw failure rates ranging from 10% to a staggering 80%.
Ouch.
The models hallucinated impossible molecules, proposed conditions wildly outside the physical parameter space, repeated the same failed conditions, or just spit out unparsable garbage.
So direct prompting actually loses to plain old-school Bayesian optimization.
It does. Prompting alone is a dead end for this kind of rigorous chemistry.
Which brings us to disagreement number two, a paper by Cristiotti et al. called A Sober Look at LLMs for Material Discovery.
Right. They took a deliberately skeptical stance, claiming that LLMs only help invasion optimization over molecules if they're heavily pre-trained or fine-tuned on domain-specific chemistry data.
And their method, LAFT, is actually that 12.1% baseline we mentioned earlier.
Exactly. And Gollum proves that the Cristiotti paper's skepticism was aimed at the wrong target.
Because Cristiotti assumed that the missing ingredient was chemistry data.
Right. But as we saw, Gollum proves that general-purpose LLMs with no chemistry pre-training beat the chemistry-specific models. The missing key wasn't the data. It was training the representation through the uncertainty objective.
Man. Okay. Which leads to the third conflict. Another Google DeepMind paper, this one by Nguyen et al., titled Language Model Embeddings Can Be Sufficient for Bayesian Optimization.
Yeah, they argued you don't need to change the alumna's brain. The fixed string feature embeddings are good enough as they are.
But wait, we already know fixed embeddings fail. We just established that static embeddings give you that jagged cliffside map.
Exactly. The new paper dedicates an entire diagnostic section to dismantling this. The Elaine geometric finding proves that fixed embeddings are exactly the failure mode. Their geometry is fundamentally misaligned with
what the surrogate model needs to accurately predict outcomes.
So if you don't let the marginal likelihood physically reshape the embedding space, you are working with a broken map.
You're lost in the maze.
Okay, let's unpack the final and definitely the sharpest conflict here. This is from a team at Carnegie Mellon, McKnight et al. In a paper called Pre-trained Knowledge Elevates Large Language Models Beyond Traditional Chemical Reaction Optimizers. Right. They benchmarked
LLM-guided optimization on six categorical reaction datasets. and concluded that frontier LLMs consistently match or exceed Bayesian optimization just through prompting. Bayesian optimization only kept an edge on explicit multi-objective trade-offs.
This is the freshest tension in the field right now. You have two highly respected groups looking at LLMs and chemical optimization, and they're reaching totally opposite verdicts on whether prompting alone is enough.
Hold on. How can two brilliant labs look at the exact same underlying technology and see totally different realities? I mean, someone has to be wrong here, right?
Not necessarily wrong. It comes down to the terrain they're testing the models on. Midnight's tasks at CMU are focused on fully enumerated categorical spaces.
Which is like discrete lists of options, choosing catalyst A, B, or C.
Exactly. Whereas the Gollum suite is much heavier on mixed and continuous spaces, which are vastly more complex.
Oh, okay. It's a classic case of the tool fitting the terrain. Like if you're on a perfectly paved road with clear road signs, a discrete list of categories, simple prompting might actually work. Yeah. But if you're in the continuous messy jungle of mixed variable process chemistry, prompting gets you
lost immediately. You need Gollum's actuary holding the leash.
Precisely. And the two papers also use completely different success metrics, which contributes to the divide. But most importantly, McKnight's own framing is that pre-trained knowledge aids exploration rather than replacing structured search.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah, that underlying philosophy isn't actually that far from what Gollum is doing. Gollum simply argues you need the Gaussian process to discipline that exploration when the math gets continuous and messy.
That makes total sense. Now, with any scientific breakthrough, we have to look at the honest limitations before we just, you know, declare total victory.
Yeah, Gollum is not magic. The authors are very transparent about where this currently falls short.
Let's bring it back down to Earth.
First is computational scaling. Standard Gaussian processes scale cutically. As you add more data points to the history, the compute required skyrockets.
So if you want to run a laboratory campaign with thousands of experiments rather than 50,
this exact setup will choke. You would need to introduce mathematical approximations to handle that scale.
Got it. And there's also the limitation of using text to describe physical reality, right? We're shoehorning 3D chemistry into English strings.
Exactly. If you're working in a design space that lacks a clean linguistic structure like trying to describe complex 3D protein conformations or highly intricate crystal structures, a text interface might fundamentally be the wrong
tool for the job.
Right. You can't just describe a folding protein in a paragraph and expect perfect geometry.
You really can't.
Yeah.
And finally, we have to acknowledge that all 23 benchmarks in this paper are retrospective.
Meaning they're fully enumerated historical data sets where the answers are already known.
Right. They are not live, messy, real-time laboratory campaigns where, you know, the ambient humidity in the room might suddenly ruin a reaction. Validating this in a closed-loop, self-scribing laboratory is the necessary next step to see if it actually survives
contact with physical reality.
Even with those limits, though, the paradigm shift here is undeniable.
Oh, completely.
The closing line of the paper is the ultimate thesis worth landing on. The authors state that Gollum provides a path to specializing foundation models, not through pumping them with more data, but through richer, uncertainty-guided information.
It challenges the entire scale is all you need philosophy in AI.
Yeah.
For years, the assumption has been that to make an AI better at a specific hard task, you just need to feed it a billion more tokens of specialized text. Gollum proves that calibration beats raw data hoarding.
Which leaves you with something pretty profound to chew on. If calibrated uncertainty rather than more data is what truly specializes a foundation model for a high stakes domain like experimental chemistry, what else does that recipe apply to? Exactly. Think about it.
What other fields rely on massive amounts of text but require absolute mathematically calibrated confidence before pulling the trigger? Could we use this exact deep kernel learning architecture to navigate the maze of medical diagnostics? pairing messy patient histories with strict
probabilistic outcomes?
Or could it revolutionize high-frequency financial markets or complex legal policy? Any domain where being confidently wrong is catastrophic could theoretically benefit from this exact architecture.
The battery in the flashlight is still limited. We still have limited time, limited money, and limited resources to solve the world's biggest problems. But if we can train our models to map the walls of their own failures, maybe we finally found a way to stop checking the empty hallways. Thanks for joining
us on this deep dive. Catch you next time.